On the 23andMe website, there's a full service called DNA
relative finder. That actually generates an IBD, or Identity by
Descent Score for you. And compares it to that of
other individuals in the database.
Attempting to actually make family connections.
Most people you find on a site like this will
be cousins. Many distant cousins, in fact. But you just
might find a closer relative that you didn't even know
you had. There's an added procaution on the 23andme site that
asks, are you sure you want to opt in to see these close relatives?
Can you think of a reason that you might not want to participate in finding
close relatives? Go ahead and think of a response and put it in the
text box here. And consider checking out
the forums to see what your classmates think.